Thank You Christian for the inter listen
yes so just before we start we'd like to
introduce ourselves I am Daniel this is
my colleague Rachel
I'm a senior data scientist here in
Berlin moving from Brazil four years ago
and currently I'm working for an
e-commerce doing machine learning models
for predictive analytics I am also a
volunteer at data science for social
good Berlin and as mentioned I'm a
teacher at data science bootcamp and I'm
Rachel I'm from the US but I've been
working as a data scientist here in
Berlin for the past two years I also
teach you a data science bootcamp here
in Berlin and as Christian mentioned
both Donnie and I are two of the
cofounders of the AI guild which is the
go-to community for data scientists
engineers machine learners basically
anyone doing anything with data and what
our goal is is to accelerate the
adoption of AI in Europe so if you're
interested in hearing more about that
you can find us at the end so now we
starting with the topic so Bobo
it stands for fear of better options it
gives a name to the spiral we fall into
when we obsessively research every
possible option when we are faced with a
decision view you will miss out on the
best one so it looks like we are always
optimizing and living in the world of
maybes we can't be paralyzed at the
prospect of committing to something
because we fear that we are choosing
something that isn't the absolutely
perfect option so that can be
overwhelming and it can block us in the
reality we know that we'll never be able
to examine every possible algorithm
package technology tool before we have
to make a decision in our data science
project specifically when we are talking
about data science we can think about
all the machine learning algorithms we
have and how to choose from them so here
I have an overview map of the machine
learning algorithms from this blog post
of data science for everyone and we can
see here it is split into four main
categories classical learning deep
learning reinforcement learning and the
in-sample methods some of them even
subcategories for example in classical
learning we have supervised and
unsupervised learning but it looks like
it's a lot of options a lot of choices
to me maybe it gets better if we just
focus let's say on Python
implementations and even on one package
so the most popular package for
classical learning for example
scikit-learn so yeah we still have too
many choices this is an interesting
overview because it also tries to give
us a path so we have a start and
depending on the situation we are in so
we can find what is the most appropriate
for our case but this is only for a
classical learning what about deep
learning so here in overview 11
different Python frameworks and
libraries to work with deep learning and
we know that every day more and more
packages are being released new
algorithms are being published so how
can we handle that so this is one of the
reasons why data scientists have this
fear of a better option so the field is
growing very fast and it's always
progressing that means as data
scientists we will have some gaps in our
knowledge base yes it isn't comfortable
to feel like you don't have all the
answers when you are new to the field
especially if you're fresh out of
academia or from a research background
maybe you're focusing too much on the
technology and on the theory not on the
application managers also focus on the
hype something that we saw on the
previous presentation instead of
focusing on the applications and the
implementations so when you are new to
the field
everything seems equally important
because or it seems better than what you
know just because it's new and this is
something that we have to watch out for
example when we are interviewing or
hiring so we have a story we want to
share yes so in an interview that I did
actually not too long ago with a very
senior head of machine learning at a
pretty well-known company
I was asked so are you the type of data
scientist who would be coding a neural
network from scratch and putting that
into production and I kind of thought
about this for a second and then this
person elaborated and said you know
because we're really concerned about our
ml IP and obviously writing for example
a neural network from scratch so in
numpy a and putting into production is
not the best idea obviously there's so
many well tested open source frameworks
and packages but then also this is in no
way your intellectual property
necessarily if you're basically copying
from scratch what has already been done
so yeah a lot of times this does come
from from managers who really are also
kind of following this hype yes and yes
that can be really overwhelming so maybe
the first solutions that come to mind
are the most high paid ones the ones
that you hear about in the media and
maybe they're not the best feeding ones
so how should we decide what to use what
if we make the wrong decision and we
don't bring enough value from the
beginning or what if with what we choose
to use isn't the state of the art now
don't despair so this is what the
presentation is going to be about we are
going to present here a practical
roadmap for our data science project
split into three parts we start in what
to focus on first then how to choose the
algorithms and most importantly how to
iterate on them and the last part is
about sharing some tips for convincing
business leaders to focus on what works
and not only hype so what to focus on
first maybe you have seen this already
the data science pyramid of needs it was
published it on hacker noon and you can
do it we can think about this as in
parallel with the human pyramid of needs
on the top of it we have AI and it would
be the human need of self-actualization
and yes it's great but we as humans
first need food shelter and water which
would be data literacy data collection
data interest
so here at the bottom of the pyramid the
first three slices they're about data
collection creating a reliable data flow
and data pipeline and doing data
cleaning and some data preparation on
top of that we start aggregating some
data and generating metrics also
collecting label data for training the
machine learning models and then the top
top two slices are about starting with
simple machine learning algorithms and
building a framework that allows
experimentation so something that we
need to iterate on so we can gather
feedback from the end users and also
pass this feedback of the models to the
business stakeholders and as we move up
with more complex algorithms we reach
the top of the pyramid with deep
learning also this is a very famous
chart and people that are working as
data scientists can relate to this a lot
of the times people think that AI is
about coding and about the algorithms
about building neural networks but in
reality we know that a lot of the work
is getting the training data and you can
think about this because big companies
like Google Amazon Facebook they are
publishing their research with the
latest algorithms but they're not
sharing their data and getting training
data might seem like it's a simple task
at first but I can give you an example
let's say you have a big catalogue of
for example wine and you want to use
machine learning to uncover what is the
best wine from this catalogue and you're
saying well okay to start with this we
have to collect some data so let's say
we will try to find what is the best
wine but what do you mean by best so
first we have to agree on a definition
of best let's say we agree on a rating
from 1 to 10 and because we wants to
collect data a lot of data and we wants
to collect it fast we ask everyone here
in the room so every time you're
drinking some wine takes some notes on
the name of the wine and put it the
rating on it so after a couple weeks we
have a lot of data and we can
use that as a training set in trainer
model right what can we expect as the
performance of such model it's tricky
right because the taste is very
different from one person to the other
so it could be that we have the same
wine with different ratings and it could
be also that the variance of the ratings
are pretty big so something that taste
is good for me is awful for you it's
also tricky because what constitutes a
good wine might not be something that
you can quantify for example the smell
we know that the smell affects the taste
well how can you quantify smell so that
means a task that sounded simple in the
beginning might need some iteration and
you might want to change your strategy
in this case for example instead of
having one model considering everything
as one training set maybe you want to
have different models or maybe you want
to take the ratings for the same wine
and take the average of them we just
need to remember that the machine
learning is only one part of the
solution so here there is this data
science environment diagram which was
published by the Google researchers we
have 15 different components in data
science and machine learning is only one
of them and a small one and it's one
that cannot leave out by itself so it
needs everything around it we have to
think about a data science solution as
building a system and to end ok cool so
now you want you know that you have to
start by understanding the parameter of
needs and where you are and also
understanding where you want to achieve
and this is not done only with the data
scientist this is this should be done
together with the business so they
understand what is the process that you
are trying to optimize or what is the
problem you are trying to fix we should
also involve the data engineers or the
software engineers in the process to
understand what is the data looking like
where is this final solution going to
live and how it will work now that we
know where we are and where we want to
go how to get there what is the path
looking like
we have to start choosing an algorithm
and it really helps when we think about
the entire process as iterations so
taking almost all of the 15 components
of the data science environment and
organizing them in a sequence we can
think about two main loops so we have
the big loop which is for the final
solution so where we're starting
defining the goal and defining the
metrics defining what should be the
minimum viable product and then we start
the development cycle which it contains
the collection of data data preparation
training the model and evaluating the
model once you run through the cycle of
iterations and you have a model that
fits what you define that first as a
measure then you can go for the
deployment start making the predictions
and you monitor your system together and
analyze some insights so the idea here
is to really have this fail-fast
attitude so you want to debug iterate
and experiment this instead of
perfection you should focus on iteration
have a good enough model to start with
and then ship it get some feedback
improve on it and repeat the cycle the
more you do it the better it gets
it's the snowball effect so you'll
better understand the algorithms you are
working with you will be better at
anticipating how long it takes for you
to finish your project
you'll be faster to a spot low-hanging
fruits for a model improvement if it's a
new model if it's on high per parameter
tuning if it's on feature engineering
also it's easier to stay motivated after
the first results that might be poor but
when you understand this is only the
first cycle of iteration and you're
doing a lot more then you are improving
and the end you are going to be able to
solve bigger problems using machine
learning so when your very first
starting so say like you have your use
case you're starting to model one of the
things that as data scientist we forget
a lot of the time is to
art with a lazy estimator so this is
something that your that's not really
going to give you a ton of predictive
power but it's really to set the
baseline and figure out for all your
future modeling if that's actually an
improvement on the lazy estimator so for
regression problems this means always
predicting the mean or the median so
that's what this is here you have the
actual target variable on the right and
then we were just predicting the mean a
lazy classifier is always predicting the
most common class one example could also
be for those of you who were at the talk
just before this when Alexander was
talking about the typical Titanic
problem everyone knows if you just
predict that women always live in men
always die you get 80% accuracy so then
that helps you kind of figure out okay
when you have 81 percent if you hadn't
done some type of lazy estimator like
that you might think Oh 81 percent is
pretty good but if you're actually only
getting one percent improvement over a
lazy estimator then that's actually not
such a great improvement and so any
machine learning or any more significant
model or more complicated model that you
should very significantly outperform
this lazy estimation but then a lot of
the times too it can be difficult to
know where to go as your next step so
actually modeling as a data scientist
there are a couple of good rules of
thumb for example with binary
classification problems always starting
with logistic regression for regression
problems starting with a random forest
is usually a good rule of thumb but it's
important to remember that there's no
one model that works for every problem
but another really good rule of thumb is
to not start with under all Network why
they take a very long time to actually
train and tune so when you're working
with neural networks you're not just
tuning hyper parameters you're also
tuning architecture and there's almost
an infinite combination of architectures
and hyper parameter combinations and
this just takes way too long when you're
coming from a place of fast iteration
failing fast you want to just get
something working
that can be up and running really
quickly another thing is that neural
networks only really show their true
power and their true success with a lot
a lot of properly labeled
data but this talk is definitely not
anti neural nets obviously deep learning
has made amazing strides and really
improved a lot of use cases but that's
just the thing it's very good for very
specific use cases like image
recognition or again when you have
really a lot of data but for the typical
first modelling that you need to do
especially in a lot of companies
settings where maybe it's not a
specifically AI focused company like a
company that's really focused on
autonomous driving but rather for
example an e-commerce company with a
specific use case wanting to use machine
learning most the time of neural network
is not the place to start
another thing that data scientists
sometimes forget is to try in Sambas of
models particularly also using different
models or even if it's the same
algorithm so train on slightly different
data for different possible
distributions within your data set so a
good example of this might be sales data
that's drastically different on certain
days of the year or week so say you know
you're a retail store and you have
drastically more sales on Saturdays and
on holidays sometimes it can make sense
to train a separate model just on those
days but the point with all this is to
really focus on getting something
started right away and then anything
that you do on top of that so whether
it's feature engineering whether it's
trying different algorithms or training
different models that should be with a
purpose to actually cause improvements
over some baseline that you have so it's
really focusing on what is the output
what why do we need another increase in
accuracy or what metric are we actually
trying to improve and why does the
business
that rather than focusing on the
technology like okay I really want to do
deep learning so yeah those slides were
really about as a data scientist kind of
cutting through the hype and knowing
where to start when you have a use case
but there's kind of one level above this
which is how do you define that use case
so um McDonough mentioned when you have
you know a person coming from your
company and saying I want a model that
predicts the best wine then you kind of
need to work with that person and say
okay how are we going to define the best
wine so setting your expectation of what
what is the metric where is this
actually going to be used because a lot
of the time most of the data scientists
in the room will understand this feeling
of a business person just coming and
saying I need a perfect model that
predicts X and then the first question
should be okay but where's that
prediction going to go who's going to
use that is the customer going to see it
is it an internal model for say the
marketing team who's the end user and
then once you have that use case then
figuring out okay is this something we
actually need machine learning for to
start should we start maybe with just a
rules-based approach so once you have
that use case this is kind of a
managerial side something that's
becoming more popular it's in a lot of
companies it's still the case that data
science teams are very siloed so you
have all the data scientist sitting in
one place sometimes they kind of work
with one business person or something
like that but we're moving more toward
this idea of execution teams so this
means that for a given use case you
build up a team of product owner data
scientist data engineers so data
architects that's people again working
on every step of that hierarchy UI
designers basically you're really trying
to integrate across the entire
organization and make sure that it's
something that's an end-to-end product
and something else that's really good
for really focusing
on and deciding on a use case is this AI
product canvas project canvas use me
sadhana uses this in her company I think
it's a really great tool
so the square in the middle is
highlighted because you always start
with the value proposition and then you
can totally see how when using this
something like show me the best wine
really breaks down if you make that
person say okay so what's the value
proposition of that it's just having the
best wine that's not a no value is
coming from that so what are we actually
doing is the value proposition okay
we're going to show the best wine for
that given person to then make them buy
more wine and then increase sales then
the value proposition is very clear but
that's also a very different problem and
then you've started to actually narrow
the focus of the use case yeah and then
also then you would have to go back and
change how you were collecting determine
three or four examples so when you have
this define it from the beginning you
can iterate faster it helps you to be
more effective and you can also as you
start to fill this out then maybe that
changes how your execution team will
look so as you start to fill this out
and you realize for example following
the wine example again if we decide okay
we do want to make it really a
recommender system for kind of each
customer maybe you need someone with
kind of specific skills there on your
execution team yeah so this is what
we've gone through so far so for so
these most of these are really tools for
particularly the data scientist in the
room but also managers so if you're a
data scientist bring some of these
things to to the business folks that
you're working with and the managers
when they say hey I think I could have a
use case try bring the AI project canvas
to that meeting um try bringing the
hierarchy of needs looking at okay for
this use case what data do we actually
need do we have that do we need to work
with maybe a data engineer to collect
more for example you know maybe adding
new points in Google Analytics something
like that and just a final takeaways so
we split four data
scientists and for decision makers yep
so the first three are separate for each
for data scientists again really really
focus on something that delivers value
and you should always be thinking where
is the prediction from this model going
because if it's just like dying in a
duper notebook that's not helping anyone
so what team is using it who is the
final recipient of whatever prediction
and that will really help you focus on
iterating quickly getting something out
there and really focusing on why you
actually need those improvements if you
need improvements in your model make
sure you're communicating with business
people throughout the whole process and
get used to showing beta versions and
showing okay we've done this so far
we're here on the hierarchy we have the
data this is what we did for the past
two months because otherwise it can be
hard to keep business people involved
and excited and also make sure you're
integrating with those teams you have
poor decision makers is to understand
the machine learning workflow and the
iteration in cycles is different from
software development workflow and how it
is important to define the use case and
the metrics from the beginning because
this will allowed for the iteration to
be guided let's say having a through
Northstar but for both sides data
scientists and decision makers it is
important to integrate with the other
team so to work together across
functionally to set expectations from
the beginning and to have the mindset of
experimentation and iteration this is
what we wanted to share with you thanks
for listening to us thank you if you
have any questions
[Applause]
we have time for questions then thank
you for your talk it was quite
interesting I wanted to ask let's
imagine the situation when the company
is not really data-driven and like only
the team of data scientists it was just
like organized and the executors they
don't really understand yet how they can
define clearly what do they need to
predict so how do you advise like who
should make these decisions should data
scientists like prepare some kind of
like detailed explanations so things
they can do or how can it be here like
organized if there are just needs
science is no data architects yet no the
people who understand how it's all like
conducted with the means of data science
and machinery I think that what the
beginning should be really about
educating and having this overview of
what a data science project is and all
of the components that it involves so
maybe you were as a data scientist you
are focusing on the machine learning
part but you need the support from
everything else around it and one way
that I have been like practically doing
this is using the canvas so when you
have a meeting it's like let's say a
kickoff meeting for a project and you
have there the data scientists if you
have also support from engineers you can
have UX designers if it's a facing
customer application and the business
people so you have everyone together in
the room and you try to figure out first
what is the value proposition to
understand what is the value for the
project and it looks like it's a simple
question
but I have experienced being a meeting
for one hour just to fill this one part
of the canvas and when you have this
value proposition understood and agreed
between everyone so everyone is on the
same page then you start going to what
is the data we need for that what are
the kind of skills we need for that
we already have them what is the output
going to look like how this will be
integrated and who else is involved as a
stakeholder and its customer and maybe
you will figure out yes I'll have some
cost but I'm also generating some
revenue so this is a good framework to
iterate on this is what I want go away
and do it and then this really
encourages them to be involved because
we never know what we are going to have
before we look at the data and we know
that we are clear on that
but maybe the expectation on the other
side is not like that because they have
never worked with data science before so
it's about understanding that we have to
iterate maybe also on the business value
we will iterate thanks for the great
talk first of all I have one question in
the pyramid that you described when you
finally get to do the AI part what is
the what you produce the the artifact is
it an analysis that allows people to
make a more informed decisions or is it
a product in the sense that gets
integrated into a software and supposed
to run for a couple of years so yeah
just to reiterate with the mic um my
it's at the top is because at that point
it should be something that you really
need AI for deep learning for so in that
case for example it's really getting
like that last improvement and accuracy
on something that was already there
that's already out so for example with
our wine prediction there's already been
something rolled out maybe with a
simpler model but maybe it's just not
getting that such a great increase in
sales and so the
and adding deep learning at that point
would be to actually you know get that
XML greater sales so it's hard to say
really like ahead of time until for each
use case until you're actually there
what it should be if I can add to the
wine module example so when you just get
asked as a data scientist you get asked
we want a machine learning model to
predict the best wine and you don't know
what what is the use of that model so it
could be that we are producing wines and
we want to understand what are the
attributes that constitute the best wine
so we can produce that best wine ever
and for that maybe you don't want to use
zip learning because you can't really
explain the result but and on the other
hand maybe you just want to have a
really good personalized experience for
your end customers and you want to
predict the best wine so they will buy
the wine from you then it don't doesn't
really matter how you can explain the
model it just matter that you get it
right so that's why also it's important
to think about how it connects to
business in the end of courses with data
scientists we also want to work on the
most accurate model possible that is
always the goal but it's good to
understand how it is going to connect in
here I have one more do you have any
recommendations if I want to raise the
awareness or the understanding of of
this whole data field among the
non-technical staff in my organization
and stuff like there there was this
thing a couple of years ago that the
government of Finland decided that we
want to Train 1% of the population
in data literacy and it's not happening
in Germany at the moment as most of you
probably know but we have to start
somewhere where would you start so there
is a really good course online free in
Coursera called AI for everyone from
Andrew ng so that is about explaining
the basic terminology and what is AI
capable of doing or machine learning
capable of doing what is not capable
and try to demystify a little bit what
we hear on the media about deep learning
and AI taken over all the jobs so that
is a good start I think - for business
people and especially managers the
important thing is to really yeah start
with what it can do for the business and
also to really like not focus on a lot
of buzzwords because especially high
level managers do not want to feel
stupid or like they don't know what's
going on so you really have to start
with them okay the business is already
doing really well here's what you don't
kind of help them feel company and then
say okay here's though what what use
cases we could actually use because then
it feels so much more real yes and
building upon the presentation from
before it's also about building trust
and communicating so everyone is working
together to have the best solution it's
not only the data scientists are not
only the business partners if there are
no more questions then let's thank the
speakers again thank you
[Music]